there are more than fifteen hundred
mosques across the uk
and for more than two million muslims
currently living in britain it's a place
to pray and promote peace but promoting
peace is hard in the face of hate and
for this community it's on the rise we
found that almost half of mosques which
were surveyed
were subject to racially motivated as
religiously motivated attacks within the
last three years and that's because of a
backdrop of islamophobic narratives
which are being peddled
throughout wider society
according to data from the muslim
engagement and development group
otherwise known as mend
42 of mosques and islamic institutions
have experienced religiously motivated
attacks in the last three years
and 35 percent experience a religiously
motivated attack at least once a year
with racially and religiously aggravated
offences increasing by 15 percent in the
last year
worrying but not surprising especially
for those that attend this mosque at
finsbury park
where a terrorist drove into worshippers
in
2017
killing makaram ali and injuring 11
others
our communities still feel the fears and
the intimidation and also you know they
expect probably an attack anytime
because what's happened just only it's
not one-off
attack on the community
we fear that
probably other attacks might might take
place unless we do something about
islamophobia in a statement the
government says we take a zero tolerance
approach to all forms of hate crime
we're taking steps to safeguard places
of worship with a grant of over
24.5 million pounds available this year
men say that only a third of mosques
that applied for the government place of
worship fund actually received it
it's asking for it to be more accessible
so that mosques that are at risk can be
better secured and worshipers can pray
in peace
shaman freeman powell sky news